une reconnaissance de 35 mm d'épaisseur
c'est avec cette création que choukour
vient d'obtenir un award la façade fws
35 panoramique design représente deux
ans de travail en allemagne maison mère
de l'entreprise et un nom d'adaptation
par les équipes françaises c'est une
demande récurrente aujourd'hui du marché
un besoin un accès à la transparence à
l'extérieur une perception une
visibilité et justement les solutions
des produits aluminium sont en temps
normal un frein donc plus on minimise
l'impact de la masure mais on se porte
aimions profite justement de l'ambiance
extérieure
la finesse a toujours été une recherche
notamment de la part des architectes et
on le voit aussi un bien-être un confort
pour l'utilisateur final
installé depuis 1965 en france choco
travail l'aluminium et le pvc et conçoit
façades fenêtres et portes
le site emploie près de 300 personnes de
la création au test vous avez en fait en
fonction des typologies de produits soit
on va partir d'un travail mené en prêt
au préalable en allemagne et sinon il ya
des produits qui sont franco français
que nous développons en totalité ici au
père en yvelines donc on part d'une
étude de marché d'une définition de
produits d'un besoin
et puis après on va tout simplement
travailler le développement ou
l'amélioration d'une gamme existante la
façade primé est commercialisé depuis
l'entreprise distribue en métropole dans
les dom-tom l'afrique francophone et
l'afrique du nord